all the old sin right is a beloved
character who persisted for many years
until her sister untimely
untimely passing the age of maybe timely
younger than anyone thought he was only
in the 70s but oh but he he was
introduced in a piece that was one of my
favorites that we did back then
in 1994 there was a baseball strike
right and um so to entertain people
while baseball was gone we staged games
between
a bunch of like six-year-olds versus
really elderly men like and in their 70s
and 80s and they were fairly competitive
games
I remember that we had used that actor
uh William Preston once before then in a
sketch about the oldest James Bond or
the oldest Spy or something but all
right but then we brought him back for
this and uh
and we named him Carl Aldi Olson and he
was the second baseman and uh
and I just remember having an amazing
time uh working with all these it was
just the dumbest premise well those are
usually hard actors to work with oh I
mean older people and kids are
notoriously difficult yeah but here
they're really it was mostly them just
playing baseball like serious trying to
play baseball against each other
five-year-olds against the 80 year old
men that's a good way to keep them from
being hams yes give them strenuously
make it competitive yeah and the old man
team was called the white stockings I
think
it's perfect Carl the Olsen just
screamed the name over and over and
laughed maniacally have you guys ever
told the story this is slightly
tangential of of when we went to
um Carl oldiel says it's a great that's
it have you told that one no no okay so
Carlie Olson was a beloved cast member
essentially that after Robert's era
introduced him in baseball we just went
back to the well many many times he's
always really funny he was a he played
the the sexual Pilgrim or horny Pilgrim
in like a Thanksgiving Day sketch we did
and
um was it there a Vampire series Empire
then he was Frankenstein's monster he
was a million different things I think
you actually eventually Sweeney may have
worn him out on a remote uh on a hot day
where he was I'm not saying you killed
Carlos well I think I I think you're
saying exactly that job
my name is on the closet it was um yeah
off the uh running of the bulls in
Pamplona uh like we had all these
characters on the show so I thought oh
what if we do a thing where it's our
annual running of the late night
characters so we had them all running
and one was Carl Aldi Olsen in Manhattan
in Manhattan and
um
yeah so anyway
he passed away right he was not a super
healthy man he was a chain smoker and
his incredibly hilarious laugh I think
came from a lifetime of
tobacco lung disease yeah tobacco
ingestion so we've but we found out
about his funeral and we went and we saw
an obituary I think that got published
in the like Columbia Pennsylvania
newspaper yeah and it said Carl holy
ghosts and we're like oh we were sad we
love kills Sweeney he was the sweetest
man and he loved the gig and he was so
happy he was like a really respected I
think theater actor guy and now he was
doing this funny stuff and he was he
lived right near you know in Hell's
Kitchen and he was you know in Times
Square and he was just a real sweet guy
and we were sad to lose him as a friend
and also sad to lose this really funny
character and so I remember somebody
found his obituary and it said that he
was survived by a twin
identical identical twin brother oh my
God so we went to the little memorial
service like a week later in that was at
a little theater in Hell's Kitchen
cameras and and I Conan went and now we
have to go now we have to go we're gonna
go anyway and now we have to go and I
just remember Conan joking like could I
get a gun that would because he showed
up and he was a more robust version of
Carl of William Preston yeah um and he
did not have a beard and and the long
hair that William had and but Conan was
joking like is there any way I could get
a gun that would fire a beard
[Laughter]
but yeah we met him and we when we
didn't know any of that and it was very
sweet and we well you know he was a
beloved uh
that was amazing because he he was the
we thought of him as one of the most
unique people you could find anywhere
and then oh no there's an exact
duplication
I'd love it if the twin had been working
on the show I mean it was maybe it was
the twin the whole time well they heard
I was still working there so he was I
mean I'm not going near there it's not
gonna kill me like you did my brother it
did cross our minds it felt in bad taste
to like in late night fashion to like
send Mike Sweeney and a cabinet crew a
cat camera crew too right wherever this
gentleman lived and tried to convince
him to be a part of our Repertory
company but we we talked about John wow
and there was because Carl
became the ending to so many comedy bits
you know you're like how do we get out
of this with a big yeah oh yeah
just bring an oldie to do the yeah to be
the the closer right it's so funny that
people just went nuts when he would
enter a scene yeah for sure so then it
became next stop Abe vagoda hahaha